packet of information
that you've continually referred to as
sarah
afraid of the dissipation of the
death of that packet are you afraid of
death
do you ponder death does death have
meaning in this process
of creativity i think i have the natural
biological urge that everyone has to
fear death
i think the thing that i think is
interesting is if i think about it
rationally
i'm not necessarily afraid of death for
me because i won't be aware
of being dead but i am afraid like for
my kids because it matters to them
if i die um so so again like i think
death becomes more significant as a
collective property not as an individual
one
yeah but isn't there something to fear
about the fact that the way
like the creative uh
the complexity of information that's
been like created in you
yeah the the fact that it kind of
breaks apart and disappears it doesn't
but i don't think it disappears it's
just not me anymore
right so you're but the that process of
you it being not you anymore that
doesn't scare you
of course it does the mystery of it i
mean the yeah but i guess i'm heartened
by the fact that there will be some
imprints of the fact that i existed
still in the universe after i leave it
yeah but there'll be a
okay but and also that has to do with my
perception of time right so
you know i perceive time as flowing but
that might not be the case
i mean this is you know standard
physicists comfort is you know
every time moment exists you know and is
you know there's no
and the flow of time is just our
perception of you know
us um you know us changing
um so you can travel back in time and
that's comforting
like from a physicist's concern no no
i'm not talking about traveling back in
time i'm just saying that the moments in
the past still exist
um now whether the moments in the future
exist or not is a different question
that's not comforting to me in terms of
death
the flow of time is not that does not i
think uh
i think it's i think there's no comfort
in the face of death
for what we are uh because we like
existing and i think it's especially
true if you
if you love life and you love what life
is
do you think there's a certain sense in
which the fear of death or the fear of
non-existence
maybe fear is not the right word is the
actual
very phenomena that gives
birth to existence like maybe death is
fundamental like
this it just feels like freaking out oh
this ride ends is actually like
the that's that's the thing that gives
birth to this all
this whole thing yeah that like it's
constantly is matter constantly freaking
out about the fact that it's
good no i think i think things like to
exist i think they want to exist yeah
there's a
there's a desire whatever to exist yeah
and there's a drive to exist and there's
a drive for more things to exist
i guess um yeah i would like to i like
existing i like i like
i like it a lot um and i don't know it
any other way
but i see i don't even know if i like
existing i think i really don't like not
existing yes yeah that's you
yeah yeah maybe it's that i some days i
you know i might like existing less than
others but
yes but like i think those are like
surface feelings there is yeah it seems
like there's something fundamental about
wanting to exist
no i think that's right but i but i
think to your point that that that might
go back to the more fundamental
idea that you know if life is the
physics of existence and maximizing
existence individual organisms of course
want to maximize their existence
and everything you know like wants to
exist but i guess for me the small
comfort is
my existence matters to future existence
you